when do you find time to watch this I
mean you have to bend your own show that
is a very unique situation to be here I
am such a Binger are you oh okay like my
free time I'm like reading or binge from
TV right so I'm lucky that I have 15
that's a lot of television and these are
9 episode seasons these are 24 hours 24
hours couldn't be that hard you can pull
this off I'd sure enjoy the holiday
trying day one you joined the cast but
when did you join the family when did
you start to feel like you were part of
them as opposed to just the new cast
member I know this might sound odd but I
felt that I became a part of the family
the first minute I walked on so really
and it was even before I showed up for
work I just went to meet people and say
hello and the first time I met Mark
Harmon
it was the after Paraguay episode where
he's all beat up and had been tortured
and he is like has you know all these
prosthetics made he's like hey nice to
meet you and everyone couldn't have been
nicer and more welcoming so let's talk
about Jack that's amazing did you have
anything to do with that at all actually
the writers and I George and Frank and
were the showrunners we talked about her
having a guy's name so yeah before she
walked in a room people wouldn't know if
she was a man or woman and they said
what about Jack Jacqueline then great
that's incredible have you figured out
her ultimate purpose yet do you know
where they're taking her what's so fun
working in this atmosphere is I have no
idea even what my backstory is I have no
idea where Jack Sloane came from or
where she's going what I do know is Jack
Sloan is very much her own woman and
really likes this team keep forgetting
you really get away you do as you know
Canada loves Mark Harmon have you
figured out yet what it is about him how
could you not love Mark Harmon
okay the first day I go to his house
he's wearing shorts and flip-flops was
working like making a cabinet and picked
me cucumbers from his garden right he's
like that guy
I think the most genuine down-to-earth
handsome kind yeah I call him the
captain of the football team right why
is this show the number one show in the
world for 15 years I think it has much
to do with Mark Harmon who he is as a
person